I'm gonna get so many followers never
never doing that again I'm never doing
that again
[Music]
hi everyone it's Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see spider-man
far from home now it's been out for a
couple weeks
Kevin Feige in the director has started
talking about what they're doing with
spider-man 3 I know there's a lot of
questions there's a lot of new rumors
they came out about a special deal with
Sony about the movie having to earn a
billion dollars or Sony gets the rights
to spider-man back and Marvel loses the
character
don't worry I'll address all that in
this video there's a new brand of that
IMAX ticket giveaway all you have to do
is enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite spider-man moment on the
video so I broke this down top-10 style
I know you have a lot of questions about
how Nick Fury is going to get involved
with this how is he going to help
spider-man because it seems like he
would have the technology for proving
that Mysterio's videos fake news what's
gonna happen with the sinister six
characters that they teased in the
spider-man homecoming post-credit scene
but spider-man 3 basically think about
it this way
is basically the John wick 3 of the
franchise spider-man on the run from
everyone it is hunting season
quote-unquote so remember that idea so
starting in the mid credits post credits
scene number 10 spider-man goes on his
date with MJ web slinging around the
city in the new Steve Ditko upgraded
spider-man suit it sounds like he just
reprinted a new copy of the same suit
using another one of Iron Man's special
printers just wherever he found one
because I don't know that they've
rebuilt the Avengers base at this point
but their Stark Enterprises buildings
all over the place it's a multinational
billion-dollar corporation so they would
have facilities everywhere all over New
York City that Peter could go to to use
another one of these printers because
they haven't rebuilt the Avengers base
though more on the future of the
Avengers team at the end of this video
Sam Jackson was actually teasing about
fury putting together a new team of
Avengers during all the press for
spider-man far from home so very
exciting stuff 9 they land MJ has the
opposite reaction to web slinging from
all the previous versions of her
character completely loses her [ __ ] and
says they're never doing that again
it's meant to be a joke because of
course he's going to have to save her at
some point during spider-man 3 with all
the villains coming for him and it'll
involved web slinging around the city
you remember Kirsten Dunst character she
actually really enjoyed swinging and
then Gwen Stacy during the Andrew
Garfield era all them loved web slinging
was spider-man 8 as he goes to leave
there
News broadcast that airs the fake
footage that Mysterio shot and edited of
their final fight on the London Tower
Bridge it's a worldwide broadcast in the
newscaster most of the public watching
all over the street seemingly totally
believe what Mysterio tells them in the
footage but he tells them that
spider-man mysteriously attacked him
without warning he doesn't understand
what's going on I don't know why he just
turned on me then tells them the
spider-man proceeded to evil guy
monologue hilariously his way through
their fight telling Mysterio that only
he would be Iron Man's true successor
then makes it look like Spiderman
ordered this whole cyclone monster drone
strike on London Tower Bridge 7 that's
not all they also say another source has
even more footage with another separate
video from Mysterio surprise is JK
Simmons coming back as J jonah Jameson
my entire theater erupted in applause in
tears when he came on-screen this new
MCU version of the character is more of
a video blogger conspiracy nut yelling
into a camera instead of yelling at
newspaper journalists but here's the
footage of Mysterio publicly outing
spider-man as Peter Parker showing a
picture of Peter Parker then makes it
look like Spiderman killed him so J
jonah Jameson calls Mysterio the
greatest superhero in the history of the
world blames spider-man for everything
setting the stage for one of the
greatest and most classic rivalries in
the comics
spider-man versus Jay jonah Jameson he
basically calls out spider-man on
national television and implies everyone
should want him dead he's basically
taking out a hit on spider-man without
actually taking out a hit on spider-man
but six that's not all Mysterio's videos
and jay jonah Jameson's call to action
do because the news was broadcast all
over the world now everyone both regular
people and all the Marvel villains who
want Peter dead know who he is
Kevin Feige just revealed that the story
of spider-man 3 would be one that we had
never seen before on screen that could
be any number of stories I mean there's
a lot of different Spiderman stories
they haven't done yet but the reason why
I'm calling this the John wick 3 of the
spider-man movie franchise is because of
what the director said in the villains
he wants to use for spider-man 3 just to
address the rumor about Sony taking the
character back if spider-man far from
home doesn't make a billion dollars
because it sounds like Kevin Feige
thinks that they're making spider-man 3
Amy Pascal also said that Spiderman
would be with Marvel for a long long
time but just a couple days ago there
was a famous blogger named Richard
Rushville who's relatively well
respected said that he learned special
details about Sony and Marvel's sharing
arrangement for the character in part of
the terms of the agreement he claims is
is that if Sony does not make a billion
dollars on spider-man far from home then
Marvel loses the right to make
spider-man 3 I would be skeptical about
that but I think it's a moot point
because spider-man far from home is on
track to earn a billion dollars so I
don't think that it's gonna matter
either way whether or not that's true 5
he mentioned paying off the Scorpion and
vulture spider-man Home Coming post
credit scene scorpion and his friends
want spider-man dead and the reason he
says that they didn't cameo during
spider-man far from home is because they
spent most of the movie in Europe in the
story was more about spider-man
wrestling with his identity by the end
of the movie he finally accepts his role
he he knows who he is and what he's
going to be doing going forward but then
there's that big twist where they pull
the rug out from under him and out his
identity so he was like holy crap what
am I gonna do now so that's why they
didn't want to go full-blown sinister 6
right away before the director also
mentioned that the main villain he
wanted for spider-man 3 was
even the hunter so I everybody freaked
out when they heard this the other day
Kraven himself obviously wasn't in the
movie but there was a reference to
Cravens last hunt at their hotel in
Venice the hotel's name is Hotel de
Mateus which is a reference to J M
DeMatteis the very notable writer of
Cravens last hunt he wrote a lot of
other big spider-man stories but the
most famous story that he wrote was
Cravens last time one of the best
spider-man stories of all time is
everything all right there were a lot of
other references to other big spider-man
comic book stories and writers I'll post
a link to my spider-man far from home
Easter Egg video at the end of this
there were a billion Easter eggs but
there were a ton of scenes during Spider
Man far from home that logically set the
stage for how Kraven could show up in
spider-man 3 there was a series of
deleted scenes at the beginning of the
movie that's gonna be on the blu-ray
with spider-man
taking down the Manfredi mob it was all
those scenes in the trailers of him in
the iron spider suit taking down those
mobsters that's the Manfredi mob from
the comics aka Silvio Manfredi
Silvermane spider-man took him down they
want him dead so they could hire Kraven
the hunter to hunt spider-man down three
Kraven in the MCU could just be someone
looking for the next big hunt challenge
the way he does in the comics and decide
that his next big target is spider-man
the world's number one most wanted
because thank you very much Jay jonah
Jameson Hayling Mysterio is the greatest
superhero in the world and spider-man
just killed him
so spider-man is like the FBI's number
one most wanted criminal right now even
though technically he didn't do anything
wrong
there are a number of other major Marvel
comic book villains that they haven't
done in the new MCU movies yet like
Norman Osborn or other big villains that
would have the money to hire Kraven if
they wanted to get their hands on the
Edith glasses because he still has the
glasses at the end of the movie he's
walking at a JFK Airport with them on
his shirt
so all those orbital weapons platforms
all the drones all that extra technology
that we didn't see but that exists
villains want that just as bad as the
heroes do but number two you probably
heard that Sony is also planning on
doing their own Kraven the hunter movie
set inside the venom verse there was
a very prominent Craven Easter egg in
the Morbius movie behind-the-scenes we
saw there's a Craven off truck so even
though we haven't even seen the trailer
for that movie yet they're still trying
to say that oh yeah we're definitely
gonna do crepe and at some point Marvel
almost used Craven as the villain for
the first Black Panther movie before
they decided to do the kill monger plot
I think it was the right choice but they
were just gonna save Craven for a later
movie ostensibly for a spider-man film
and sinister six action later on but if
Marvel wants to use Kraven now they
actually have to make a new deal with a
V Arad who's in charge of all the venom
verse movies Amy Pascal is only in
charge of the Peter Parker MCU
spider-man movies all the other Venom's
spider-man related stuff is a completely
different group of people led by a via
rod which I'm sure he would be happy to
loan them Kraven the hunter but that
means that they would also have to
probably give something from the Marvel
Universe to him but at the end of the
day no matter who the main villain is
it's still John wick 3 everyone coming
for spider-man all the villains who know
his secret identity
but all the heroes and all the FBI
Homeland Security regular law
enforcement agencies so but his open
season on spider-man but number one real
challenge he faces now isn't getting
Nick Fury's help to figure out a way to
disprove all the fake news that Mysterio
created to prove to the public at large
that he is the hero that they can
believe in in a lot of you asked why
didn't dick Fury help him out during the
film after that because obviously they
just wanted in on a big WTF moment and
based on the way they played that last
post-credit scene it seemed like Nick
Fury had also done the very spider-man
Peter Parker thing of turning his phone
off and just ducking everyone's calls
for a little while because he
quote/unquote wanted to go on a vacation
post Avengers end game fake Talos Nick
Fury even has a joke earlier in
spider-man far from home during a scene
when he first shows up in his hotel in
Venice were they referenced the funeral
in why Nick Fury didn't introduce
himself and get spider-man's number
you're a very difficult person to
contact spider-man their explanation was
just that it would have been
inappropriate because it was a funeral
it was really sad and he didn't want to
try and do something like that when they
were trying to honor Tony Stark's memory
the Drakkar also clarified that Nick
Fury actually went to outer space and
Talos came to take his place right after
avengers endgame so
it's not like he's been a scroll for the
last couple of movies he was real Nick
Fury during Avengers endgame and
Avengers infinity war we learned about
an alternate ending to the movie and a
whole bunch more deleted scenes I'll do
videos for that stuff in the next couple
of days but leave all your Marvel video
requests in the comments the Marvel
Comic Con panel is happening next week
on Saturday night of course I'll do a
video for whatever footage they drop
whatever they announce it's gonna be
crazy everything you've wanted to know
about Marvel phase four click here for
all my spider-man far from home Easter
eggs and click here for all my post
credit scene videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]